imaginemos que tenemos dos catapultas la
primera catapulta que dibujamos aquí con
todo el proyectil lo que hace es que
cuando alguien la activa ya sea
presionando un botón o levantando una
palanca esta catapulta se va a liberar
su brazo se va a mover cierta distancia
y se va a detener aquí el proyectil será
lanzado con cierta velocidad inicial
esta es una catapulta pequeña también
tenemos una catapulta grande que vamos a
dibujar más o menos así su brazo es
cuatro veces más largo que el de la
catapulta pequeña esta es la catapulta
grande y no olvidemos dibujar su
proyectil al ser liberada la catapulta
el brazo recorrerá el mismo ángulo y
lanzará el proyectil esto les va a ser
útil cuando construyan su propia
catapulta este proyectil tendrá una
velocidad lineal conocemos algunas cosas
acerca de estas catapultas para la
catapulta pequeña el radio que hay entre
el centro del proyectil y el centro de
rotación de la catapulta es r en el caso
de la catapulta
y su radio es 4 r también conocemos la
velocidad angular con la que se mueve el
brazo la magnitud de la velocidad
angular de la catapulta pequeña es o
mega si la escribiéramos como vector
sería un vector negativo porque vemos
que se mueve en sentido horario y la
convención nos dice que esta dirección
se considera negativa esta magnitud de
la velocidad angular es igual a 2 y
radiales por segundo ahora con respecto
a la catapulta grande cuando el brazo
está en movimiento la magnitud de la
velocidad angular con la que se mueve es
igual que la de la catapulta pequeña dos
radiales por segundo aquí la pregunta es
cómo se compara la magnitud de la
velocidad del proyectil lanzado por la
catapulta pequeña no tiene flecha arriba
porque no es un vector es la magnitud
del vector o la rapidez como se compara
esto con la velocidad del proyectil
lanzado por la catapulta grande ambas
tienen la misma velocidad angular pero
tienen radios diferentes pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta aquí el punto clave
es darnos cuenta de la relación entre la
magnitud de la velocidad angular y la
magnitud de la velocidad lineal como ya
hemos visto en varios vídeos la magnitud
de la velocidad angular multiplicada por
el radio va a ser igual a la magnitud de
la velocidad lineal la velocidad del
proyectil de la catapulta pequeña que
escribimos como uve pequeña será igual a
un mega ambas omegas son iguales
multiplicada por el radio que es r a que
será igual v grande será igual a la
misma omega multiplicada por 4 r y no
sólo r como en el caso anterior también
lo podemos reescribir como 4 por omega
por r y qué es esto de aquí es la
magnitud de la velocidad lineal del
proyectil de la catapulta pequeña aquí
tenemos la misma velocidad angular pero
si incrementamos la longitud del brazo
cuatro veces la velocidad lineal también
aumentará cuatro veces así que la
magnitud de la velocidad lineal del
proyectil lanzado por la catapulta
grande es
a 4 veces la magnitud de la velocidad
lineal del proyectil lanzado por la
catapulta pequeña nos vemos en otro
vídeo